[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA CHOMIK-MORALES:
I'm Jessica Chomik-Morales,
and I'm a neuroscientist at
the McGovern Institute at MIT.
I use a brain imaging technology
called Functional Magnetic
Resonance Imaging,
more commonly known
as fMRI, to see which
regions of the brain
become active when
we do certain things.
Studying the brain
is a passion that
arose from being an only
child to immigrant parents.
I grew up observing how
cultural differences can
drive differences in behavior.
My family is from
Asuncion, Paraguay,
this really oddly shaped
country in South America.
I'm producing a neuroscience
podcast in Spanish
to bring free and
valuable information
to the Hispanic community.
I know from my own
experience that there are not
many Hispanic people
in the sciences.
And on top of that,
most scientific content
is available only in English.
But I'm going to change that.
My podcast is called
Mi Última Neurona,
which translates to
"my last neuron."
I hope to inspire
the next generation
of Hispanic neuroscientists
with this podcast.
[MUSIC PLAYING]